it's expensive to be poor in America
because you have to have a certain
amount of income to have a bank account
and if you don't you end up having to
use about ten percent of your income
just to use your money that's ten
percent that you could be using to buy
food a car education so you overdrawn
your account for a little bit you get a
thirty five dollar fee you don't pay
that off you get another $35 right
quickly those fees add up and it turns
out that it becomes very expensive to
have a bank account if you have too
little money so the unbanked is those
who don't have a formal bank account but
there's also a sector of people who are
under banked right so that have a bank
account but use payday lenders as their
main access to financial services they
look like their informal mom-and-pop
shops that got these neon signs it seems
very much part of the community but
they're not they're multinational
massive corporations that are highly
profitable how do they make profits they
make profits because people are poor and
they need these services and so they
charge the absolute maximum allowed by
law so if you need to borrow $400 and
you go to a payday lender you end up
paying something like fifteen hundred to
two thousand dollars by the time you're
said and done so that is the difference
between remaining a solvent sort of
financially healthy individual to being
bankrupt people that don't have bank
accounts are people who have low income
right so it's a lot of times people of
color the military senior citizens
students a lot of banks over the last
several decades left low-income
neighborhoods and as soon as these banks
left they created banking deserts and
this is when the payday lenders and the
check cashers moved in very quickly to
fill these market voids we used to have
a lot of community banks bankers who
were part of the community they stay in
the community and grow the community
over the last thirty years we have small
banks swallowed up by medium-sized banks
and they're now just mammoth size
things that's why today you have five or
six big banks that dominate the banking
industry our democracy is much healthier
when we all have equal access to
financial services and credit and so far
we don't have that